do you still want to do something that's
just straight stand up though
maybe in a few years i just have some
other goals i want to get out the way
right now which are what
well the first one i wanted to work on
uh a film which we worked on it was
called [ __ ]
and then we uh yeah it's perfect i love
that title that's the best title ever
is there any better title than google
yeah yeah and so i got that out the way
in the film we're gonna submit sundance
and everything else like that you made
it
i don't know yet so we're gonna submit
it what do you mean did you write a
script
we shot it in everything oh so you shot
a movie yeah called [ __ ]
yeah are you who's in it your star uh
justin chan oh he listens to this i
think this podcast yeah
justin me justin and this uh young girl
named camilla and this guy there was no
role in there for me or
[Laughter]
you know what you know what you would
have done it for free too i think just
for the title alone
i think justin was looking at you to
cast as my brother
but then he he decided that he was going
to do it himself
because he didn't know if you know what
i mean so i don't know yours okay
i don't know what you mean it was his
vision so like he didn't know
if somebody else could do his vision the
way he wanted it or something
what's his name justin justin justin if
you're lying twilight
he's on twilight he was in twilight the
asian guy in twice oh yeah he's cute
justin listen to me right now next time
just next time just open your heart up
and just go uncle bob uncle pump
your
that would have been nice would you have
done it yeah he would want that on his
imdb just from the title
alone i would have forced him to do it
hey can you do you want to do
yeah i'm in do you want to know what it
is no word on nope
are you sure i want to be exactly no i
wish i would have known that
well that's you know what you should
take risks like that
group but i don't think i don't even
think that you guys would have put me in
it's fine let's move on
no yeah that's not true now that you
know
now that i know this yeah yeah i mean if
it's called
let me ask you this was there a real
crew it was it was done on the 80k
budget though
that's fine for free it's an indie film
yeah
he's so angry i told you he would have
done it for free he absolutely would
have done it for free of course
i've done a lot of things for free
you know i i mean for me it's like when
i did that movie with
arden marine just like this summer that
one with the
teenagers that yeah there's cute kids in
it you know and
you know they're real legitimate young
hollywood kids in it
but the money was what not good no okay
you know i'll go
i read it i go yeah i like to play that
and i do it
yeah you know i mean you have to pay me
something
but i don't need it you know but also i
i feel
as though we talk about it anytime he
gets offered something
and we read the script together and if
it's something that's compelling to me i
always tell him money or not do it
yeah awesome like he'll turn down bigger
things and bigger money which he did for
that movie for that one
you turned on something much bigger to
do with small i was i was offered just
two weeks ago
a lead of a full-blown movie what
yeah and i go i don't want i don't like
the premise of it
i don't want to do it wow i still want
to do it you know and so
um look at you mr hollywood no i'm not
saying that i'm just saying that
i say no to a lot of things but there
are some things that i
just gooks to me sounds like something i
would want to do
yeah it's a dramatic about the ellie
riots that's
[ __ ] better you're breaking his heart
right now you're breaking my heart dude
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah if it gets into
sundance too because my pilot
i did a pilot for comedy central a lot
of it was taki
took place in the l.a riots i love the
l.a riots it's my favorite ride
out of all the riots like watts you know
why because our people wasn't it
yeah that's why yeah and you know what
people don't talk about that perspective
either they
you know there's the black whites but
dude [ __ ] there was people on ruse
with chocolate
shut people down because you know that
was some real [ __ ] people don't talk
about that
yeah yeah you know that that is a very
that whole thing though
between i don't think it's a thing
anymore
the tension between koreans and black
people
but back then it was a thing i feel like
it's still a thing
no because they no i i don't i don't
personally but maybe you're
not you personally but from what i've i
just not just koreans i think just
asian people are just asian people hate
asian people like yeah extremely
a lot i make fun of asian people all the
[ __ ] time for no reason
but it is weird that asians would go
into
urban communities to open up liquor
stores
to enslave the people even more
basically we open up a store that sells
a drug
right which is chains yeah and we could
do it in suburban places or whatever
but we choose these specific communities
because we know
that we can make more money that way not
we as a me i would never do it
but i'm so and then also when you open
up a store
in the urban community and every once in
a while maybe there is going to be
a black person that steals but then you
make the assumption that everyone's
going to steal and so then you come up
with things like you touch you buy
no browsing what they used to say no
browsing what is that
don't what does you touch you by me and
it's like i can't touch it and read
how much it is yeah but when black
people used to go to korean liquor
stores they would put
you don't touch you know the negatives
put it back down don't touch
but then again it's like but then they
were all weird because we had shotguns
on the
you know on the roofs inside that's not
my business like i'm gonna protect it
[Music]
you